Let's go to our caller from the 5 1 2 area
code who's calling today from 5 1 2.
Hello.
Yeah, that's you.
All right, good.
How's it going, Packman?
Good name is Enzo. Lorenzo, you said Enzo.
Yeah.
From Southern California.
Enzo.
Okay.
What's going on?
Yeah, so I've been going around your subreddit,
I've been seeing a lot of the commentary that
people are saying about the primary race.
So a little different from the whole corporate
scandal that's happening.
Yep.
But something I wanted to ask about that people
seem to be freaking out is on the issue of
Supreme Court justices.
There seems to be this notion, I guess, from
a lot of progressive people that Biden is
going to cue a center right judge or a centrist
judge instead of choosing someone from the
left.
Do you think that fear of any way, I guess,
apparent?
I mean, listen, Biden is certainly going to
choose someone more to the center than somebody
like Bernie Sanders would be likely to select.
But, you know, to say Biden will choose a
right wing judge, I've not seen anything evidentiary
that would suggest that.
And again, I think the real question is who
would Trump pick versus who would Biden pick?
But no, I would assume Biden would pick someone
whose center left, but certainly not far left.
That that that would be my best guess as to
who Biden would select.
I guess as a follow up to that, do you think
it's better that someone would choose a far
left justice because we always feel like the
Republican side from like all the Bushes and
even Trump.
Now you're always choosing guys just like
far right judges.
Do you think it would be fair for the Democrats
to try to at least put someone back that would
be, I guess, progressive for like 20 more
years and all standards?
I actually have a different take on that question.
There really aren't that many, quote, far
left justices that would be likely candidates
for the Supreme Court.
I mean, like today, who?
Who's I don't know who is considered to be
furthest left on the Supreme Court?
I'm sure there is someone.
But I don't know if it's like Sotomayor or
Kagan or, you know, Ruth Bader Ginsburg or
whatever, but there's nobody that's very far
left on the court right now.
I mean, a case you have, you have certainly
it's a range that I believe goes from pretty
far right to center left as it is.
And you the point that I think you're making,
that's the really good one, is are there even
any truly far left people that someone like
Bernie would even be likely to select?
Because the slate of folks likely to be chosen
from is going to be people that are sort of
nominally left people in the kind of Obama,
Clinton, Biden era and a little bit left than
that.
So I also think it's important to manage expectations
about what we mean by a super left Supreme
Court justice anyway.
I don't think it's that likely because I don't
think there are that many candidates that
would be likely to be seriously considered.
Yeah, absolutely, I think, you know, we're
thinking on the same level here about the
whole justice issue.
So that's what few thoughts I had about who
Biden would take down like some of the issues
about that.
Yep.
I think it would be a center left person and
they would probably be slightly more centrist
than who someone like Bernie would end up
with.
And that that that's where I see it.
Thank you for the call very much.
Appreciate hearing from you.
Hope to hear from you again.